because learning thinking we're in it
for clicks
well that's funny
not flash rooted in substance today we
talk with our patch
right every moment
the Cinderella story is over man right
they're fighting for clicks we're
fighting for wins there's a difference
right there's a difference right this
game ain't gonna be playing
games
so funny to me bro
he knew the camera's in there he ain't
seen nothing all week and then he said
something game day hey we let him we let
him
hey bro we don't care about people
talking
because Linda is a good coach I still I
still think so he recruited me when he
was at Georgia he had a great guy to me
so hey he he did he found somewhere to
fire his team up in that's what he did
Coach Brown kept it real after the game
they translate in practice it is I don't
say stuff just to say it for a click you
know uncontrared to what somebody say
but uh yeah I keep receipts uh
but I'm serious I analyze and I
understand what we're up against and
what we have and what we need one thing
that I could say honestly in candidly
you better get me right now
this is the worst we're gonna be
somebody yeah I got Messengers
a blessing though man he's a great coach
he did a great job God bless him he can
take these shots they won I don't shoot
I don't do that they won
simple
yeah I never heard no team in our mouth
we don't
take shots out of the teens bro we take
the shots and keep it push you like that
you people other teams just get phased
at us posting on posting our clips and
stuff bro we don't talk about nobody
that's what we have going on is so funny
how everybody is focused on us like
other teams are focused on us hey bro
we just do it we do best